в грунт А собі коментар вітаємо вас Ми
раді що ви з нами
великий транспорту політичної проект
згуртувати Східну Європу запланований
водний шлях довжиною 2000 км
простягається від Польщі до узбережжі
України добре для економіки їм погано
для природи та навколишнього середовища
і
у Костянтина чекало є демонстрацію на
його річці
подорожі на весла голова білоруської
екологічної групи багна організовує уже
впродовж трьох років
він хоче розповісти звичайним білорусам
про незайману природу на Прип'яті і
висловити протест проти водного шляху є
40 який може з'явитися
ще з дитинства Костянтин бачить себе
захисником тварин і природи
це місце унікальне Адже люди може
приїхати сюди і подивитися як виглядали
річки раніше якою була колись природи в
Європі
якщо ми збережемо ці великі площі дикої
природи то збережемо також екологічну
рівновагу на Європейському континенті в
а й 40 пройде посередині 11 білоруських
заповідників і може зруйнувати цілі
екосистеми кажуть активісти водний шлях
має з'єднати Балтійське море з чорним
через середину Полісся одного з останніх
великих районів і за плавними лісами
Європи
дев'яносто відсотків видів птахів
Білорусі також житті яким загрожує
вимирання деяких гніздяться прямо на
необроблених берегах
цього разу маршрут на каналі
простягнувся на 35 км саме туди де річка
повинна стати судноплавний деякі місця
тут майже непрохідні навіть для каное
поки що великі кораблі зашкодити птахам
не можуть група часто зупиняється у
прибережних селах там вони розмовляють
про запланований канал із жителями і
у але мали власну думку
щодо них важливіше розвиток водного
транспорту що бажання захистити
середовище і зберегти його здоровою
річко таких селах як красава завжди була
в центрі життям про запланований проект
є 40 тут до цього часу ще ніхто не чув
але деякі жителі швидко вбачають у ньому
шанс для економічного розвитку регіону
корисним раніше в Україну на річці був
інтенсивний рух і
і тоді Дуда цивілізація тоді тут
з'явиться більше людей і стане цікавіше
і ми зможемо їздити на Чорне море
Але
остаточного рішення про будівництво що
немає тому Міністерство транспорту
Республіки Білорусь а раптово скасовує
запланований інтерв'ю щодо є 40 Утім
голова транснаціональної комісії
експертів із є 40 підкреслює переваги в
одного вантажного транспорту він є
екологічно чистим а наземні маршрути
перевантажені вже зараз
багато учасників
Костянтин може розповідати їм в мої
побоювання через є 40 адже Він впевнений
Білорусь
екологічний туризм ніж перевезення
вантажів і
[музика]
у
Болгарія в азартні лихоманці найбідніша
країни Європейського Союзу має всього
сім мільйонів жителів але продає близько
ста мільйонів
наприклад у гірському селі неподалік від
столиці Софії стійко тримається
як переможця лотереї адже один із них
уже мав Колись дуже великий виразний о
у маленькій гірське село чи кальчево на
віддалі 50 км від Софії виглядає на
перший погляд іде вічно але тут панує
гірка бідність у селі живе лише 300
людей
у
живопису
життя важке оскільки наша пенсія мала що
зможемо за таку пенсію Ми не можемо
поїхати ми нічого не можемо в
у справі не може бути не може а
у
роботи тут майже немає тому єдиним
променем Надії для багатьох є
національна лотерея адже
обіцяють своїми грошовими виграшу ми
вихід із бідності якщо пощастить
як Георгій у лазареву героїв села рік
тому він з однією єдиною Скретч лотерею
виграли 50 тисяч євро яким він досі
залишаються у чи кальчево єдиним хто
виграв найбільше
тому що моєму житті немає нічого іншого
Правда в нашому житті немає нічого і
жодних законів єдиною правильно справу є
лотереєю що ти виграєш Якщо ні тоді ні
Це все
вона сама є завзятим гравцем
[музика]
щомісяця витрачає на лотерею перерахунку
близько 50 євро в А я ніколи не
вигравала більше ніж 75 євро в
о.в. а деякі коли вони нічого не
виграють швидко розчаровуються
вони це фірма нові ігри Софії їхня
реклама в Болгарії повсюди в інтернеті
та на телебаченні Болгар справді
затоплюють обіцянками майбутнього
багатства
також переможець міг цілий день
почуватися телевізійною зіркою у
в Україні бракує позитивних почуттів
усіх аспектах
людям позитивні емоції заряджають їх
хорошим почуттями вони є тоді нашими
клієнтами і отримують насправді
задоволення як можна стати залежним
купуючи Лише кілька лоттери щоб пошукати
щастя
психолог має іншу думку Звісно що ігрова
залежність Болгар проблематично
розчарованих людей в
а
він купив для своєї молодої сім'ї
будинок але віднедавна автомеханік
безробітний і боїться що буде вимушений
продати свій будинок і
у
мрії що живуть у гірському селі чекан
чево але багатство приходите не
поширюється все далі І далі
у незвичайному столиці Боснії Сараєво
висить дитяча гойдалка вона нагадує про
похмурий період історії Європи стала
символом долі що спіткала дітей під час
кривавого конфлікту між сербами
хорватами та постійними початок 90-х
років став кошмари
османович її довелося тікати від
солдатів що наблизилися впритул І ще це
в дитячому віці також була і доля тисяч
інших дітей під час боснійської війни
спогади про цей час не дають спокою і
досі які потребу розповісти іншим
історію свого життя а
[музика]
А чи від куль уламки гранат Це будинок з
якої довелося втікати Він все ще є німим
свідком війни що більш ніж 25 років тому
увійшла в життя і міни тоді вона перед
вікнами раптом побачила танки в
в
очах свого батька я зрозуміла що
трапилось щось страшне
і мені тоді було вісім років які
дівчинці що нині живе тут коли з'явилися
ворожі солдати батьки вирішили
відправити її разом із сусідами котрі У
той же день втекли до Хорватії і
у печена кілька днів стало розлукою на
багато років доля занесла і міну до
Німеччини і хоча тамтешні сім'я прийняли
і відкритими обіймами Вона тужила за
батьківщиною і прагнула будь-якою ціною
повернутися до сараєва хоче там все що
лютувала війна в
у але для цього потрібен був закордонний
паспорт батьків через польських Забули
дати його з собою паспорт який вона
зрештою отримала замість втраченого став
для неї чимось особливо в
[музика]
у
музеї дітей війни у Сараєво зберігаються
тисячі подібних речей серед них і
закордонний паспорт і міни в
А за кожним експонатом стоїть доля
конкретної дитини цій сторінці зібрані
засновником музею
те що було задумано книжковий проект
перетворилися на музейну концепцію що
отримала пристрій стала моделлю для
музейників всього связана
[музика]
достатньо змінити все ж
і
дитинство в умовах війни а також за
понад 5000 дітей та молодих людей щороку
навіть музей і Вони шукають
документальні свідчення історії своїх
батьків важливою частиною роботи музею
стало виховання прагнення до Миру й
до не
о.в.
з
того часу не було того що маємо ми
будинках без їжі і води В
з газети Боснії переповнені
націоналістичними гаслами політиків але
люди втомилися від них у них купа
побутових проблем Вони не хочуть щоб
етнічний конфлікт між пояснюється мета
сербами спалахнув знову
знаходяться країни таке трапляється
нечасто з проектами Що займається цими
війни в
у але сподівається на краще майбутнє для
себе і своєї сім'ї
через кілька тижнів вона приєднається до
нього зі своїми дітьми це місце поблизу
Гамбурга де вона Колись жила коло
замкнулося а
у
1/5 старих районів покладів бурого
вугілля у Північній Греції
апостолів 33 роки він майстер підривник
однієї шахти державного енергетичного
концерну
апостолів зі своїм батьком який також
працює на шахті бульдозеристом тут
працював що їхні діти
з
апостолів та його колеги готується до
підриву породи
1200 євро заробітку не так і багато
70 молоді безробітні чотири села змушені
були поступитися місцем найбільші
копальні на балканах серед них і його
рідне село
Тут працює багато чоловіків
жінок і дітей
з 2011 року законом передбачено
відселення з
у але енергетичний концерт не хочу
платити за це а
і
немає вугілля під селом немає і
[музика]
а прямо біля села Ніко свої на
електростанція а тут працює дружина
зарплата невисока 620 є лише тимчасовий
договір вона сподівається стати штатним
працівником концерт в
а ідею цю концерн допоміг багатьом
увесь регіон живе завдяки видобутку
вугілля
в
кількох поколіннях пов'язані
у 2009 році буре вугілля давало 50
відсотків грецької електроенергії нині
ця частка впала до 30 відсотків і
і нам потрібно вугілля мені навіть
страшно уявити що було б тут без бурого
вугілля в
а через економічну кризу в Греції ЄС
вимагає приватизації частини концерну
вирішили відмовитися від видобутку
вугілля інвестори не вкладають гроші в
і жодних дощових хмар
завис вугільний пил
та дуже потерпає від екологічного
забруднення А про відселення і мови
немає
громада не вкладає гроші в розвиток села
приреченого на загибель скаржиться
на місцях не веселі
[музика]
інколи Смертельний в у спробі корів
причому тварин які допускають Одна за
одною своїх корів якщо ті одна хочуть
цей день повинен стати великим
селекціонер жанклод
грунт але перед тим як вийти на ринг
Санта ну потрібно зважити 672 кг значна
бойова вага в
у Сантана корова гірської породи сильна
і войовнича
а константа на
національних змаганнях
якщо буду для цього певні обставини в
[музика]
і боротися не примушують ж одну корову
о.в.
а
програє виключається
Вистава що має традицію
а
сила якою володіє тварина Тварина
проявляє у боротьбі Це просто чудово
захоплююча без поранень боротьба без
жодних ран і
а сьогодні боротися будуть майже 120
корів
викликають на ринку в
у бойовий запал виглядає інакше в
а
потім протестантами хочу виступати саме
одна сковорідок
в лоб
в бою не відбулося
у to bring Забирає свою корову прямо
зараз
добробут Та немає для нього першорядне
значення
а потім розчарування великим
у Santana Santana мала бажання боротися
Я помітив що тоді коли вона не тоді
краще
але за останніми подіями в
e-ips трохи боляче це в крові
селекціонерів в
А у Великому фіналі перемагає Фаворитка
дзвіночок для нової королеви
Київ 2019 рік і
[музика]
о.в.